[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de las alertas más
recientes que han generado las
organizaciones climáticas que dan cuenta
de los daños irreparables generados por
los humanos al planeta serían cuatro los
indicadores clave del cambio climático
que registraron valores sin precedentes
el año pasado el 21 hablamos de las
concentraciones de gases de efecto
invernadero la subida del nivel del mar
también las altas temperaturas y la
alice eve y acidificación de los océanos
el más reciente estudio de la
organización meteorológica mundial
confirma que los últimos siete años han
sido los más cálidos de los que se tiene
constancia estas condiciones
meteorológicas extremas provocan en el
año 2021 pérdidas económicas millonarias
también pérdida de vidas humanas y
disminuyeron gravemente el bienestar de
las personas además de alerta atentar
contra la seguridad alimentaria e
hídrica y agravar los desplazamientos de
las personas saludaban entonces a
nuestro segundo invitado el día de
sebastián carranza oficial a cargo de
cambio climático para onu medio ambiente
de américa latina y el caribe gracias
sebastián por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 nuestra
región de américa latina el caribe es
una de las más afectadas del mundo por
estos impactos del cambio climático
hablamos de los fenómenos meteorológicos
extremos como las sequías las horas de
calor los ciclones tropicales y también
las inundaciones que han provocado
decenas de muertes y graves daños en la
producción de los alimentos y también
por supuesto han dañado la
infraestructura que podemos esperar con
este panorama tan desalentador
gracias por tu invitación y gracias por
tu pregunta efectivamente nuestra región
de américa latina y al caribe es una de
las regiones más vulnerables a los
efectos del cambio climático nosotros
estamos experimentando pues incrementos
en los niveles del mar en las zonas
costeras remociones en masa en nuestras
zonas montañosas y lo que podemos
esperar escritos de eventos se
intensifique lo estamos observando ya es
una cosa esperada es una cosa que lo
venía observando y que lo que muestran
los indicadores es que gradualmente van
a empezar a mostrarse de una forma mucho
más agresiva donde los eventos de
ciclones y huracanes los eventos de
inundaciones y sequías son algunas de
las mayores preocupaciones para nuestra
región sebastián esperábamos para este
punto en el que estamos ahora digamos
ver cambios tan drásticos en torno a la
crisis climática digamos estas
proyecciones esperaban unos años después
y no tan antes como lo estamos viendo
ahora
y realmente es algo que hemos venido
observando desde varias décadas se ha
venido advirtiendo permanentemente que
los efectos del cambio climático se va a
intensificar y efectivamente digamos que
cada vez empezamos a observarlos de una
forma mucho más dramática yo diría que
al contrario son eventos que hemos
venido percibiendo digamos desde la
última década y que se van a mantener
durante las próximas dos décadas de lo
que él llama hoy es por un lado a
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero y reducir esas
concentraciones que tú incitarte al
principio y que además son consecuencia
de las emisiones históricas no hay un
efecto acumulativo en la moda pero aún
estamos experimentando la consecuencia
de haber depositado gases de efecto
invernadero demostrada hace dos o tres
décadas y eso va a seguir en el tiempo y
en segunda instancia pues adaptarnos a
esos efectos de un trujillano hay otra
opción más de pensar en cuáles son esas
medidas que nuestra sociedad es nuestra
economía de infraestructura van a tener
las comunidades y los ecosistemas para
empezar a implementar de una forma mucho
más efectiva descargar los efectos que
estamos experimentando a eso quería
llegar cuáles son estas acciones que
tienen que tomar nuestra región para
mitigar esta crisis climática y también
los fenómenos naturales ahí que se
presentarán a futuro que ya se han
presentando mejor dicho claro que en
principio lo más importante para
nuestras ganas enfocarnos en las
poblaciones más vulnerables tenemos un
número de personas expuestas al riesgo
climático altamente vulnerables con muy
pocas capacidades de adaptarse a los
efectos de los que nos estaban
conversando entonces las políticas
climáticas deberían poner a estas
personas en el centro de su discusión en
segunda instancia y no menos importante
nuestros ecosistemas somos una región de
cada diversa en donde muchas de nuestras
especies y ecosistemas pues están
altamente expuestos a los efectos del
cambio climático entonces el riesgo de
perder especies en riesgo de perder
ecosistemas sensibles como pueden ser
algunos ecosistemas montañosos las ondas
páramos tienen en el norte de los andes
pues es un riesgo
inminente
deberíamos también sebastián empezar a
pensar en la migración climática a estas
poblaciones que pues se tienen que
migrar de donde se encuentran ahora
digamos las grandes ciudades para buscar
refugio para no ser afectadas por todas
estas inundaciones sequías y todo lo que
vemos con la crisis climática actual en
el euro que ya estamos observando
poblaciones que están viendo afectadas
sus actividades económicas por ejemplo
están dejando de poder ejercer
actividades como la pesca o la
agricultura y están teniendo que
desplazarse a otros lugares donde puedan
seguir las actividades económicas hay
otras poblaciones que están perdiendo su
hábitat está aprendiendo sus casas hemos
visto por ejemplo en centroamérica el
corredor seco centroamericanos la costa
de honduras es una de las costas más
afectadas por pérdida de la línea de
costa en donde ya no hay inclusive vales
enteros que han tenido que desplazarse y
perder sus habitaciones
podemos sí le quería preguntar si
podemos digamos mitigar este
calentamiento global el último informe
de la organización meteorológica mundial
dijo que esto siete años han sido los
más calurosos desde que se tiene el
registro y pues vamos para allá no
parece que la tendencia va a seguir
siendo de que van a ser todos los años
que viene después uno más caluroso que
el otro cómo hacer para mitigar lo bueno
sobre todo sin antes con mundo entero
estamos depositando cerca de 50 mil
toneladas de gases de efecto invernadero
cadario la atmósfera si queremos
percibir
y una mitigación en ese incremento de
temperatura récord usted lamenta es no
incrementar más de dos grados
centígrados y hacer todos los esfuerzos
posibles por mantenernos por debajo de
1.5 grados centígrados para la mitad del
siglo deberíamos reducir esos 50 mil
millones de toneladas a la mitad para el
año 2030 es decir que el reto es
gigantes a tu respuesta es sí claro que
si podemos hacer algo está en nuestras
manos tenemos que hacerlo y sabemos
muchas organizaciones gobiernos empresas
y gente actuando en esta línea pero el
resto es del tamaño de reducir a la
mitad una cifra tan grande como 50
gigatones o 50.000 millones de toneladas
que emitimos al aumentar la atmósfera
reducir eso a la mitad para el año 2030
es decir está por el orden de 25 y
gastón es para el centro sebastián ya
para finalizar en estos últimos días
también se han conocido el dato de
contaminación digamos de los aviones y
los jets privados no de las personas más
ricas más poderosas del mundo como
contaminan en cada trayecto que hacen
con estos aviones privados además se
conoció que google parece que maquilla
estos datos de contaminación y los pone
por debajo porque ocurre todo esto y que
tanto contaminan estás en los aviones y
sobre todo los viajes privados
es bastante sensible es importante
abordar desde un frente y es recordar
que las emisiones de los aviones de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
generado por los aviones en trayectos
internacionales no hacen parte de la
jurisdicción de ningún estado es decir
esa pertenencia a una instancia que es
la organización
de aviación civil internacional que se
ocupa de gestionar esas emisiones es
decir no no podemos digamos de alguna
manera usar a un estado a otro de
gestionar esas esas emisiones entonces
vamos a observar primero en la instancia
de la de la organización de aviación
civil internacional quien se prepara
esas emisiones efectivamente es difícil
también llegar a un dato concreto nos
preocupamos mucho por el consumo del
combustible de estos seres y de estos
aviones lo que nos hace enfocarnos
exclusivamente uno de los efectos
invernaderos que es el de la generación
de emisiones de co2 por combustión hay
estudios y este ámbito hace referencia
se preocupa mucho por las estelas los
privados también se preocupan de
aeronaves que no están gestionado una
bandera de un estado ni tampoco están
gestionadas en una flota de una empresa
de aerolíneas sino que organizan digamos
a intereses bastante particulares lo
cual hace difícil gestionar esa huella
de carbono que generan los tweets
privados